there's an article by the New York Times
titled
ayale Professor suggested mass suicide
for old people in Japan what did he mean
the article says that yusuke and Narita
a professor of Economics ayal made a
suggestion in 2021 regarding Japan's
Social Security as you may know Japan
has been facing problems due to an aging
population and declining a birth rate
let me quote the New York Times I've I
feel like the only solution is pretty
clear he said during one or one online
news program in late 2021 in the end
izzini mass suicide and Mass ZIP code of
the elderly seppuku is an act of ritual
disembowelment that was a code among a
Dishonored Samurai in the 19th century
and when I read this my initial thought
was that it's a it's an awful way of
thinking taking people's lives isn't the
answer young people don't go to vote so
our voting rate is usually within within
the range of 30 to 50 percent and so
young people's voices are not reflected
in our policies because the politicians
or candidates don't have to listen to
Young people because in order to get
votes they just need to listen to the
elderly people right so
um and about as a result of that our
frustration piles up and the frustration
is real so I can actually understand it
if one uses this extreme way of
expression even though it is
inappropriate and this is the common
understanding of Japanese people about
our society that it's obvious that our
population is declining and the older
people are getting even older so that
means that our burdens as a society is
getting bigger but then young people
can't afford to support them I don't
know if we are romanticizing it but our
life and death sense is very different
from the Western countries
and we want to die in honor
that might be something that Western
Nations agree with too when it comes to
Wars but it's for Japanese people it's
not only in Wars It's everyday life that
we are very very responsible and we want
to be at our best and if if we can't
like it's I guess that we think of
suicide because we feel the
responsibility well when I was growing
up I think the retirement age was 60 but
then it became a 65 and now my parents
are working and they're around 70s and
so I feel like it's going up and up as
for the problem of birth rate in Japan
many people are talking about different
things but from Western people
especially make it more complicated than
it is the problem for us is economy the
people want to have children but we
can't afford it so so we're not having
babies and that's just how it is